Yle Areena.
Ja kulkee bussissa, ja metrossa, missä vaan.
Ihmisellä on ainoasti kännykkä kädessä, varsinkin vähän nuoremmilla.
Niin, tota, mä ehdottaisin semmoista kännykkähiihtoa esimerkiksi.
Esimerkiksi kymmenen kilometrin hiihto pitäis olla molemmis käsissä koko ajan kännykkää, ei sauoja.
Ja sit viidenkymmenen kilometrin hiihto, vaikka, olis toisessa kädessä kännykkä vaan.
Et se ois niinku semmoinen, varmaan, siihen innostus nuoretki ihmiset, että tämmöstä mä ehdottaisin, kiitos.
Jo vuodelta 2017 tulee vastaan yleisradion artikkeli, jossa mainitaan liiallisen puhelimen käytön aiheuttamat yläraajakivut.
Enkä ainakaan minä usko, että tilanne olisi tässä vuosien varrella yhtään helpottanut.
Missään nimessä en siis osoittele muita itsekin kuulun ehdottomasti ihmisiin, joiden puhelin on ilmana liimaa liimautunut käteen kiinni.
Ehkä se siitä joku päivä vielä tipahtaa, menet tiedä.
Se on Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdys.
Vilkasviikko takana päin meidän vastaajalla, ympäri Suomen saapunut hyvin monennäköistä kommenttia aina Lovisan sataman jätteestä, kittiläläisiin koiran omistajiin.
Kirjoituksen katoamista harmitellaan, ja tupakoitsijoille toivotaan puolestaan mitallia.
Ja vilkasviikko tai oikeastaan pariviikkoinen on takana päin myös tuolla Milano Korttinassa.
Koo, Mikko täältä on lolasta, ku tänä ei vartun, että on sunnuntai, että pitää tulla Kansanradio.
Syt tänne yhtäkkiä ilmoittikin, että tulee vaan pyssyhiihtoa.
Kuka sitä urheiluhöpötystä kuuntelee, hirveitä, höpötystä.
No, ei multa nii muuta, mie sain purettua tän.
Mä olen nii äärettävän vihainen.
No, höppaa.
No, morjes, tässä on Rover.
Mä ihmettelen näitä lasketeluselostajia, kun ne selittää, että ne on semmoisessa paikassa kuin sektiossa.
Eehän se voi olla näin.
Luulisin, että ne on sektorissa.
Kiitoksia, moi.
Ne on menny nämä olympialaiset pilalle, ku sylen televisiolähetykset näyttää vain ulkomaisten jääkiekkoilujoukkuiden pelejä, jo edes Suomen jääkiekkojoukkuiden pelejä, ni aina menee mäkisyppy lähetysten päälle.
Ei näy televisiossa niitä suomalaisten mäkisyppäjien hyppyjä, vaikka ollaan Suomen valtiossa, ni mitä varten niitä noita ulkomaisia joukkuita näytetää, antaa niitten pelata siellä keskenää, ja näyttää sitä suomalaista urheilusuoritusta.
Nii, suorana lähetyksenä, menkää sinne paikalle, joka kiinnostunut, ottanut ulkomaisten joukkuiden pelituloksistani, menkää sinne Italiaa, ja siellä olokaa tuotani, istukaa siellä kaukololairella kattomassa, ku ei oo edes Suomen peliä, ni mitä se tämmönen Suomen yleisradio verommaksi, ja rahoilla näytetään, tuomosta Moskaa.
Joo, siinäpä ne oli taas olympialaiset, perkele.
Joo, se on souvaripoika, joka soittaa.
Pentti Rinkola on ihan oikea, siinä ku se sanoo, että Suomi on maailman viheriäisin maa.
Nyt, kun ei pärjää urheilus tuolla, nii ne saa nii vaivasia ronssia, nii niistäki, sitten ku ne jää neljälle, ne tekee rotestia, että ne pääsis vääryelä, sitten nii muuhikkii mitallei kiini.
Tää on jotai ihan, ihan yhtää, ei pärjätä urheilus, siellä on Norjat ja Ruotsit kymmenillä kultamitalleilla, ja näillä kolmen vaivasta ronssia, niistä kiitketää lisää, että saatais ostaa.
Tää on ihan kauhea valtio, tää Suomi.
Suvi Minkkinen ampuu, muttei pummeja ammuu, Suvi Minkkinen hiihtää, muttei hiiha liian, hiljaa.
Suvi Minkkinen ampuu, muttei pummeja ammuu, Suvi Minkkinen on nyt, olumpia pronssimitalii.
Onnea Suvi, paljon.
Kantajia vaihtamalla tulokset paranee, mutta ei parane, kun aines ei pysty parempaan, eikä tule pystymään.
Ei tuota viitsi edes enää katsoa.
Tällaisen viestin laittanut veronmaksaja, joka ilmeisesti sitten laittanut television kiindi.
Televisioniosta, kuten myös radiosta, löytyy jonkun verran korjattava.
Näin se on pääteltävä, kun meidän vastaajia kuuntelee.
On se niin järkyttäväksi mennyt tuo radio, Suomen ohelma.
Ei voi muuta, kun hät, hätää huutise kuunnella, ja äkkiä lyödä kiinni.
Heippa!
Pohojenmaalta eläkeläinen ilta.
Tässä semmoista asiaa tuli taas mieleen oikein katkereella mielellä kuunnella ja kattoo.
Piti ei minkäänlaista tietoa tullu eduskunnan avajaisista, muuta kuin presidentti puhu vain Amerikan hyvästä suhteesta.
Joka kerta on niissäni ollut avajaisista puheet kummalta ki eduskunnan puheemiehetta ja presidenttiltä.
Nyt tällä lailla jätetään kansa kuulemata, että siellä vain tupistaa keskenään siellä eduskunnassa, ja siellä sitten tapellaan niistä asioista.
Mutta tämä pitää sitten tapella täällä maakunnassakin kans kohta.
Pyhkikää ne verot, helvettii niistä ratiomaksuista ja televisiomaksuista, ku sieltä ei enää tuu muuta ku niitä vanahoja, vanahoja elokuvia ja ulkomaan kielistäni.
Lopettakaa ne verot ki sitten perimätä, perikää sieltä ulkomailta ne verot, kiitos.
Minua harmittaa, minä o vanha ihminen, ja inhoittaa kattoo tulla kolomastee vielä, ku ensimainen ostettaa ruokia ja kaikkia herkkuja, ja sitten yhtäkkiä alapää roiteita.
Nänen kertoo omia hypötyksiäni, onkaan tuossa jos haki rikkaani, Tuomas.
Noita ei tarvitse mainostaa, Tuomasia, minä ei ymmärrä ollenkaan. Kiitoksia, hei.
Eikö voi lausua niinkuin se lausutaan? Geneve, eikä Geneve. Perkele teidän kanssa.
Joo, se on Jumalan Mieliharmi täältä Länsirannikolta, hauskaa päivää.
Jumalan Mieliharmi soittelee, mitenkä oot ansainnut tai saanut, titteli Jumalan Mieliharmi.
Kyllä se on tämä elämän kohtalo, joka on koulaidu minuut. Alakuu oli kyllä aikata, särmikkäät ja terävät nurkat, mutta ne on tässä maailman pyörityksessä, niin ne on yllättävästi niinku pyöristyny nuo nurkat.
Eli oot nykyään lähempänä tuolesta niinku satsumaa kuin yveistä.
Joo, mutta kuuleppakoon, mulla oikein närästää. Vaikka mä milloa aukasen tuon televisioksi, jokko sanoo tuotani, iltapäivästä, ja sieltä tulee joku moottoriohojelma, mikä miehiä kiinnostaa.
No, jokkaisella mainostauvolla, ni siellä on joku kourakko polla oottamas, että antakaa almuja, että nyt on siellä ja täällä ja tämmöstä ja tämmöstä hättää, ja lahopuukki nii huono saa kun osa nyt, niillekin pitää sitä harraaa, ja herranen aikaisentä, ku joku nuista puhuis yhtä, yhtä liikuttavasti, että ko meidän vanhukset ja meidän terveyhoito on nii huono saa jamassa.
Voitaisko me pikkuisen järjestää sitä parempaan, paremmalle taloa kuule?
Mutta eikö niissä asioissa meidän pidä kääntyä kohti tämän maan hallitusta?
Nä oon kivittäny etelää kohti, nii joka päivä heitän kakskymmentä isoa kiviä sinne päivää, ei oo tullu kuule, ei, eipa, mun pitää varmaan muuttaa täältä kuule, täältä tuotani perämereltä, nii pikkuisen lähemäs sinne, että, ko ei tuu, tuu, orpaki, herranen aikaisentä.
Sielä on tunnijun.
Eli Arkadian mäen ovi kelloa pimputtamaan pitäis mennä.
Mutta eihän ne välttämättä sitten sulje toisiaan pois, tai jos kiinnitettais enemmän huomiota sosiaaliterveysalan, sen ylläpitoon, ja sitten toisaalta taas, jos joku hyvä tekeväisyysjärjestö haluaa luonnon perään katsoa tai.
Ei, ei, tietenkää, ei, mä oon ite tuota, nii, mä oon yli neljätömitä vuotta ollut naimisissa tuon luonnon kasa sillä lailla, että mulla on kamera aina mukana.
Ah, okei.
Linnut on minun kasa ollut tuota, yli kolmekkymmentä vuotta mä oon harrastanut tuota lintuhommaa, ja ehdottamasti haluan pitää luonnosta hyvää huolen, mutta ei, ei sitä kyllä tällä tavalla.
Et, hetikö tulee joku, joku moottoriohjelma, ni sinne lyödään tuota, nii, välittömästi joku kourakko polle oottamassa.
Puhukaa niistä ihmisistä, jotka on ihan oikeasti hädäalaisia.
Et, jos kumminkin luonnon ystävä ja heikompi osasten asemasta oot huolissas, niin en tiedä, onko Jumalan mieli harmisit ihan oikea nimitys?
Se on täsmälleen oikea nimi.
Mä oon kuolee mennyt semmoisen mankelin läpi nii monta kertaa, että jos Jumalalla oot suosikki lista, niin mä oon tullut siihen tulokseen, että en oo kuule muuten siinä listassa ihan keulimmaisena.
Okei, pohjan päästä löyty.
Mutta hei, kuule, oikein paljon kiitoksia sulle, ja ei, muutako kaunista kevättä teille.
Kohti kevättä, kyllä vai. Kiitos.
Hyvä, hei, hei.
Tänne Kansanradioon on tullut muun muassa tällainen kortti, jossa on kuva veikkaampa, että juuri lentoon lähdössä olevasta haahkasta.
Kortin lähettäjä kirjoittaa, että lopettakaa se, kansanedustajien kyselytunnin näyttäminen.
Riitelevät ja ovat huonokäytöksisiä, menee ties kuinka monta tuntia hukkaan oikeasta työnteosta niiltä edustajilta.
Ei missään työpaikassa voi koko työntekijäväki kerran viikossa kokoontua arvostelemaan toisiaan tunnin ajaksi.
Se ei voimaannuta.
Laittakaa tilalle asiaohjelma, jossa opetetaan tekemään muun muassa hakuja kelalle, ettei tule niin paljoan hylättyjä, kun ei osata tehdä.
Säästyy siinä aikaa kaikilta.
Sellaista siis ehdotusta tullut meille korttimuodossa, jos sinulla on ehdottaa jotain ratkaisua seuraaville kysyjille, niin minä niitä yhteystietoja sitten kerron tuolla ohjelman loppupuolella.
Juu, hei vaan, kuinka sellaiset ihmiset, joilla on ruokaa, voivat mennä heidän jononsa, jolla on tosikysymyksessä.
Tällaiset menevät jonon, jolla on asunto, auto, työpaikka ja kaikki hyvin. Kuinka he kehtaavat?
No huomintakansanradio, minä tässä ihmettelen tätä sähköhommaa, et kun käsketää ja kehotetaan, että ottakaa nyt pörssisähkö, hyvänen aika, se on edullista.
Se viis, kuusi kuukautta kesällä on edullisempaa, et se joskus on yksi ja kaksi ja nollassa pyörähtää, niin kyllä nyt maksetaan siitä eestä.
Et, onhan tää nyt kauheeta, eihän sen kanssa voi toimia ollenkaan, vaikka sanotaan, että seuratkaa se hintaa.
Juu, on seurattu hintaa, kyllä seurattu, juu, joka 15 minuutti muuttuu, niin eihän siitä elämisestä tuu mitään, jos sitä seuraa sen mukaan elää.
Leipo minä ikään, eihän se käy ollenkaan, kupen tuunin päälle, nyt si on halpaa se hinta, niistos myytti nyt si onkin taivaissa se hinta, en, en voi muuta ku ihmetellä.
Mykko täällä huomenta, ojalan laskuovi muka, suomalaiset tupakoitsijat oltavat vuodessa, noin seitsemän miljardin edestä valtiolle rahaa.
Et, eikö niillekki oo mitaalia kohta pitäs antaa, eikä vaan kiristää sitä tupati hintaa, eipä sitten muuta kiitoksia.
Onko postin koneelinen lukija? Niin, heikko, ettei se ymmärrä tavallista kaunokirjoitusta osoitteessa.
Tässä lukee osoite epäselvä, ja tämä Tarra hirroittuna käyttää koneelista postin lukua.
Olen jo yli kaheksankymppinen, mutta vielä 1950-luvulla sain kaunokirjoituksesta kympin.
Voi olla, että hiukan tuo kaunokirjoitus on heikentynyt, mutta omasta mielestäni tämä postikortin kirjoitus on aivan selvä ja siisti.
Ei saanut syntymäpäiväonnittelua. No, soittelin puhelimella, ja onnittelin sen jälkeen, ja kihmettelin.
Käyttääkö tuota posti tekoälyä, lukemiseen vai jotain muuta älyttömyyttä?
Vai pitääkö tähän korttiin kirjoittaa pölkkyä, eikä kaunista kaunokirjoitusta?
Sinnehän voisi esimerkiksi vaihtaa sinne postin johtoon, vaikka sen tekoälyn, ja ne työttömät johtajat vaikka lukemaan näitä kortteja sinne lajittelukeskuiseen.
Tällä lailla. Hei.
Nyt on muuten paljastettava oma tietämättömyys. Niin on jäänyt korttien ja kirjeiden lähettäminen nykyään, että minun pitihan soittaa postiin ja kysyä,
että kait nyt vielä kaunokirjoitus kirjekuoressa hyväksytään.
Postin viestinnästä Tiina vastasi, että kaunolla kirjoitettuja lähetyksiä saa totta kai edelleen lähettää.
Lajittelu automatiikka, se ymmärtää kaunokirjoituksellakin kirjoitetut osoitteet, jos teksti on selkeätä.
Jos osoitetta ei automaattisesti tunnisteta, niin lähetys siirtyy osoiteselvitykseen ja siitä eteenpäin.
Kansanradion aiemmista jaksoista, myös yksi postiin liittyvä puhelu, on herättänyt kommenttia.
Kansalanen päivää, kuuntelen kansalarioa tästä postin toiminnasta kulustani, tässä on siitä yksinkertaisi kysymys, että:
Kaikki säästetään, pihistetään, mitkä ei pellatta, saahaan postiherroille vielä isommat palkat ja kaikemmat optiot kannustulisat päälle.
Siitalta se on kysymys.
Tärimittää, posti jo enää posti, minä ku tilaan jotakin.
Kaikki tilaan matkahuolun välityksellä, en enää posti, en yhtään mitään, se on nimittäin.
Se ei pella, ja se on, se on optioherrojen, optioherrojen yhtiö, tämä posti tuotanui.
Heille yksinkertää optio tuota, ja väkiä pellolle, ja siksi kestää jopa postin tuleminen.
Kaivan käsittämättömään kauan alokoeseen kirjettää paketitää, mikä hyvää se.
Ei muuta, kiitos.
Raili tässä huomenna.
Viikko siitä rouva ihmetteli, kun alokaat joutui hiihtää kovasta pakkasesta.
Mutta minä ihmettele ja kauhistelen näitä avaantoharjoituksia Lapissa pakkasta yli 35 astetta, jolloin varusmiehet saivat paleltuvaa vammoja eriasteisia.
Ministeriöstä en ole saanut vastausta tähän. Kiitos, kuulemiin.
Sellainen nyt vaan tuli tästä taas mieleen, kun jatkuvasti toiset on sitä mieltä, että on ilmastonmuutos,
ja se, että meijät tuhoaa, ja toiset sitä, että ei semmoista ollenkaa oo, että se on höpölöpöjuttua.
Mutta eihän sillä oo periaatteessa mitää väliä.
Ette jos nyt sit kuitenki käyttäydyttäis sillai, sillai niinkun kaikkien hyväksi,
eli jos omistat vaikka pihaan istuta, vielä se omenapuu, tai jollet halua istuttaa omenapuuta,
niin annan vaikka siellä luono rehottaa siellä, sitten.
Ni kyllä, kyllä ne sinne löytää lintuset ja öttiäiset ja kaiken maailman jutut.
Ja kun kulutetaan, niin katotaan vähän, että mihin kulutetaan, ja millä tavalla.
Ja sitten on toivottavasti tulos siinä, että kaikilla on hyvä olla.
Kansanradio.
No moi, tässä on Jaana. Mä oon vakituinen kansanvalion kuuntenia,
mutta, ku siellä hirveesti valitetaan tosta ruoan hinnasta.
Tokihan se tiedetään, että ruoka on kallistunut, mutta ei sitä tarvii sitä pihviä joka päivä syödä.
Ja itse, ku nytteki tuol kiehuu kasvishernari, ni toi hernepussimakso, euro viiskyt senttii,
Sitte pussiline, noita kasvissuikalaita valmiina pakkaisesta, sit sipuli.
Ni tuossa tulee ton koko kattilan hinnaks, ehkä joku kolme, neljä euro,
ja mulla on viis litraa sitä keittoa, mannan sitä naapurille,
ja sitten ite pakastan niitä rasioihin.
Et kyllä se on vähän niinkö se valintakysymyks,
että ei täällä Suomessa kyllä nälkään tarvitse kuolla,
että kyllä täällä ihan edullisesti sitä ruokaa saa.
On kyse myös ihmisen omista valinnoista.
Kyllä juurikin näin.
Mä oon välillä eläny 200 euroa kuukaudesta,
ja saanut hojalleni ja itselleni joka päivä uudet ruuot,
et se on kyllä niinkun, kyllä välillä ostan näitä punalaputettuja tuotteita,
mutten oon niitäkää joutunu hirveesti ostamaan,
ettei se ruoka nyt kuitenkaan nii, se ei ketään konkurssii vie.
Niit, oon vähän ollut kuulevinani,
et kyllä ihmiset joutuu joskus tekemään aika tiukkojakin päätöksiä.
Nii, no mut, ei mullakaan oo niinko mitään suuret tulot,
ja jää nyt tossa huhtikuussa eläkkeelle,
ni mut, et se pitää sitten niinkö miettiä, et et mitä ostaa,
ja mitä niinkö, ja eikä sitä lihaa tarvii,
niitä filet piivei tarvii, eikä jauhe lihaa joka päivä syödä.
Ehtä herneet on tosi edullisia, linssit on edullisia, niistä on ihan maukkaita ku hyvin vaan maustaa.
Ehkä sinun pitäisikin julkaista sellainen muutaman euron reseptit kirja.
No joo.
Mää lupaan, että sellaisen, jos julkaiset,
niin minä ostan ihan ensimmäisenä itse tykkää kanssa metsästä tällaisia edullisia reseptejä.
Mutta sanoit, että sitä hernekeittoa tuli viiden litran kattila,
monta annosta siitä saa?
No, Jumaa kautta, siitä mä syön varmaan koko kevään,
mä annan kyllä tuolle yläkerran rouvallekin sitä.
Sit hyvät mausteet siihen vähän, kasvisliemikuutio, lihaliemikuutiota, suolaa, pippurii, laakerilehteeni, kyllä lähtee.
Kyllä lähtee.
Hei, minä kiitän, ku soitit tänne, mainio juttu.
Kiitos paljon, päivä jatkot.
Moi, moi, moi.
Seija Tiihalan viestinähän minä luen tässä seuraavaksi,
hän aloittaa viestinsä, että eläkeläisiin kohdistuu ristiriitaisia odotuksia.
Toisaalta vaaditaan eläkkeiden leikkausta,
ja toisaalta sanotaan, että ikäihmisten pitäisi maksaa entistä enemmän itse palveluistaan.
Jos eläkkeistä leikataan, tämä ei toteudu.
Eläkkeiden pitäisi pysyä nykytasolla, ja niiden kireää verotusta pitäisi alentaa.
Näin eläkeläisille jäisi rahaa palvelujen ostoon, muun muassa siivoukseen, ateriapalveluihin ja asiointiin.
Se edistäisi työllisyyttä.
Myös kotitalousvähennyksen parantaminen tukisi samaa asiaa.
Tällaisen viestin laittanut Seija Tiihala jämsästä käsin.
Jämsästä siirrytään lovisaan, kun meillä on muutama paikallistiedoteluvassa.
Nyt minä tulen puhumaan teille paskaa.
Suomeen tuodaan paskaa Italiasta, eik se hölmä juttu, ettei omat paskat riitä.
Ai, hitto, lovisaan satamaa tuodaan paskaa, ja siellä haisee ja ihmiset sairastuu, kun tuodaan semmoista paska-ainetta.
Joo, kyllä, hei vaan.
Kansanradio.
Ku teille soitti silloin se postilaatikoihin, kusijihin kyllästyny ihminen.
Joo.
Ja oli niin oikeassa.
Mulla on nii vistotta, ko ne kehtaavat.
Mulla on ittelläki koira, mutta mie otanko jätökset matkaan.
En jätä niitä.
Ne kehtaa, pihalle päästää, ja näihin liittymihin, ja siihen valtavat kasat, ja siihen ne jätetään.
Eikö näillä ihmisillä ole omaa pihaa?
Mutta sitten mie mietin, et voisko nämä olla vuokralla asuvia, että…
Ei ne voi.
Mutta onko sillä väliä, että onko se vuokralla vai omistus, joka tapauksessa, jos ne jättää korjaamatta ja jättää jonkun toisen postilaatikon juureen, niin väärinhän se on.
On se väärin, mutta eihän ne välitää. Ne vaan miettii, että no kyllä joutaa, tuoki.
Oletko tästä jutellu naapureiden kanssa, tai?
Olen, ja kyllään oon suivaan tunne kans.
No mie sanon, että tämä on Kittilän keskustassa.
Sehän on sitten hyvä Kansanradion kautta lähettää terveiset ihan koko Kittilän keskustalle, että, jos millää viittisit ottaa pussit mukaan samalla, ku otat talutushihnaja koiran kanssa.
Joo.
Mitäköhän tohon sitten, mitä on sellaista konkreettista, mitä voitais tehdä, että se loppuis?
Niin, no…
Onko suomalaiset kuinka innokkaita kylttien, kylttien noudattajia? Mä olen huomannut, mun naapurustessa on kylti.
Täälläkin on.
No, tuossa naapurissa kyllä on, mutta siinä on riskimies, joka kuuntelee sitten, että mitä sanotta.
Jos mie menee laittamaan tuommoisen, niin mie saan ikkunhan ne paskat.
Käviskö siinä mukaa nii?
Aivan taatusti kävis.
Ja.
Oi se kyllä tylsää hommaa, toisten sotkuja korjailla, ei voi muuta sanoa.
Oi, se on niin tympiä. Ja sitten mie aloin vielä pelkäämäänkö syksyllä, elokuussaa, niin bakteeritartunnan sai tämä minun omaa.
Okei, mutta selvis siitä kumpinkin.
Selvis tietenkin, joo, mutta ei kestäis kyllä enää toista bakteeri.
Tapa, joo.
Minä kiitän, ku soitit. Toivottavasti nyt sitten Kittilänkeskustassa, kuka harrastaakin, niin menee kauppaa ja ostaa pussit, tai jos pusseja on, niin rupeaa käyttämään niitä.
No sehän se on hävetöntö, että niitä, kunta on laittanut niitä pusseja.
Ai jaa, sekin vielä.
Niitä olis, olis. Ja pönttöjä.
No sitten jo kyllä ei mitään tekosyytä, totta.
Ei, ei.
Mutta hei, minä kiitän, kun soitit aiheesta ja koiralle rapsutuksia.
No näin, olipää mukava, kun kuuhnut elit.
Tottakai, tottakai, sitä vartenhan täällä myös ollaan, joo.
Kiitos sulle.
Jo, kiitos paljon.
Paikallistiedotteista siirrytään vähän laajemmin ympäri Suomen koskettaviin aiheisiin.
Sitä ennen luen yyden meille saapuneen viestin, joka alkaa, että huom, te sivistymättömät.
Muistakaa vanha totuus, kansakunnan sivistys mitataan sillä, miten se pitää huolta heikoimmista, lapsista, sairaista ja vanhuksista.
Hei, kuuntelin tässä just A-tookkia, ja oli puhetta verotuksesta ja muun muassa pieniverotuloisten verojen käsittelystä.
Mutta, mä tiedän, sellaisia ihmisiä, joilla on pieni eläke, mutta ovat hyvin vähän tehneet sellaista työtä, mistä ovat maksaneet veroa.
He ovat esimerkiksi tehneet remonttihommia, kampaajahommia, hoitaneet lapsia, ja kaiken tämän pimeästi.
Ja nyt sitten narisevat siitä, että eläke on niin pieni.
Ja sitten he ovat kuitenkin myöskin tehneet niin, että käyttäneet, muun muassa terveysasemia, ja nehän veron rahoilla on pidetty pystyssä.
Eht, harmittaa, harmittaa suuresti. Kiitoksia, hei.
Hyvää huomenta, täällä puhuu nytten, torstai aamuna, eri ruokatuotteiden hintojen nousua.
Aika kovat nousut on sekä liitissä, että K-marketeissa.
Luen kaikki tarjoukset joka päivä, hyvin tarkalleen.
Tänä aamuna huomasin, että puolen kilona ihnerypäleet ovat muuttuneetkin neljäksi sadaksi grammaksi.
Eli voittoa hyvin paljon, saattu tarjousinta, mutta koko on pienentynyt, sitten 100 grammaa, eli 20 prosenttia.
Samoin, minuuttipileet on pienentynyt, koko hinta pysynyt, tarjoushinta samana.
Eli, kaikki tuotteet, olkaa nyt hyvin tarkkoja, kun ostatte, eläkeläiset ruokia.
Eli, pitäis vähän enemmän seurata tätä, inflaatio, paljon se on pakkoruissa, mitä ihmisten täytyy ostaa, välttämättömiä.
Jotain täytyy vetää turpaassa, vaikka sitten porkkanaa ja perunaa.
Hyvää päivän jatkoa.
No, se oo Koivuniemen herraa, tää Teteläs varmeistervee.
Miks hito os, ihmiset ei osaa relata, niiko kunnoo?
Ottaa niiko viikonloput viikonloppuna, työviikot työviikkona, okei.
Miks ihmiset ei osaa relata?
Ei tää oo sen kummempaa, ko ottaa niiko rennosti, ja miettii tulevaa, pienes, hiprakas.
Huiminen tulee, huiminen menee, näkee mii.
Vielä on tässä kansanradiossa luvassa muutamat kommentit siitä, kuinka tätä maata voisi hieno säätää, vielä vähän paremmaksi.
Tässä vaiheessa minä kumminkin jo sanon, että iso kiitos, kun olit kuulolla, ja laitetaan siihen päälle vielä kuule toinen iso kiitos, jos osallistuit soittamalla tai laittamalla viestiä.
Esimerkiksi meidän Whatsappiin numero on 044 55 154 64.
Tai sitten sähköpostitse kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Toki tänne saa korttia ja kirjattakin laittaa.
Oikea osoite on kansanradio, PL 79 000 24 Yleisradio.
Niin ja tietysti meidän vastaaja 08 00 154 64.
Ja aina sunnuntaisin, kello 12:30 alkaen, kolmen tunnin ajan paikalla, ihmis vastaaja, sisätiloissa kun ollaan, niin se on helppo luvata, että paikalla satoi tai paistoi.
Se on muuten se paiste, mitä minä ainakin toivon enemmän ja enemmän, ja näyttäis ihan tuo toivet toteutuvan, kun ollaan jo tässä helmikuun loppupuolella.
Lasse Olkinoire toivottaa oikein hyvää juuri tätä hetkeä, ja ensi kertaan.
Kanski toitselee, semmoista asiaa soivantutta liikenteelta, kun tää on menny ihan älyttömäksi tää toiminta tuolla.
Ensinnäkin nyt moottoritiellä, ajetaan toisten persauksissa kiinni, yritetään painostaa, todella huonoissa keleistä, ei mitään järkein, ootanut vaan milloin se kolahtaa kunnolla.
Toine asia, valojen käyttö, nii henkilöautoissa kuin rekoissa, hitommoiset valoheittejat on, ja niit ei osata käyttää, väärin suunnattuja valoja.
Ja ikävä kyllä rekkakoskit, ei tullut sajuu vaan sitä, että kun tullaa pienen nyppylän takaa, nii ne katolla olevat valot, nii sojottaa silmii jo paljon ennen.
Palio ennen, ku se ite auto tulee näkyviin. Se vastaan tuleva auto varminkaan, ei ite näe. Että tämmöstä, Norjessa.
Eläkärouva täällä Espoossa kokee täysin ärsyttävänä ja hyvin vaarallisena sen, kuinka eri pankit ja tutkimuslaitokset antavat viikottain ja päivittäin täysin toisistaan vastakkaisia tutkimustuloksia,
esimerkiksi asuntomarkkinoista, rakentamisesta, hinnoista, ja niin edelleen. Se jo lisää kuluttajien suurta, suurta epävarmuutta.
Niin, että pysytään aina vaan tässä samassa suossa, ei tiedä, mikä on totta, mihinkä uskoa. Siis se on hyvin vaarallista, ei muuta kiitoksia.
Vai laittaa se purra, nämä maahanmuuttajat, risu savottahan. Kyllä sinne joutaa nämä Suomen nuorekkit työttömät, pelaavat tietokonepeliä, kaiketyöt ja nukkuuvat iltapäivään.
Ja, jos ei tuolla kansanedustajan kouluutuspohjalla muuta niinku saada aikaan, eikä keksitä, niin kyllä mun mielestä on mennyt kyllä kouluutus niiltäki hukkahan.
Joo, sitä mieltä minoista, voi kissan, kusi tämä homma.
San laapin jouni, joka soittaa tältä muonion perältä.
Minä kerron semmosen tosiasian, ku tuo minun vaimo sanoi, että se alakais leipomaan tiikerikakun, ja meni hakemaan kaupasta kananmunia, ja.
Meiä panin moottorikileikan käyntii, ja me aina tuonne kirkon kylälle sitten hakemaan niitä kananmunia, ja.
Meiä meni siellä kauppaan, ja.
No, siellä oli luomumunnaa, ja oli ruskia munnaa, ja oli valkia munnaa, ja oli pientä ja isova munnaa, ja.
No, sitten siellä mie katoin, ni siinä lukkee kuulee, että viiriäisen munia, ja mie katoin aukavasi sen rasia, ja mie katoin, että.
Ihminen syyvä tämmösiä, kun oli semmosia pilikulisia, ja.
No, siinä sitten semmonen keskiikänen nainen tullee, kuulee minun takkaa, ja mie kysyn siltä, että.
Anteeksi, ny vain toi ta rouva, mutta.
Oletteko te maistanu viiriäisen munnaani?
Tämä nainen sanoo mulle, etteihän mie etäs tunnes semmoista, koko miestä.
Ja, mie olin ihan häkeltyny siinä sitten, ja.
Ei munainen pitää olla, ja.
Miet olin kotiana, se vaimo sitten lähti itte autolla, ku.
Ettei mulle on pa sen kummempaa muuta, ku se, että ku tämä EU on noita muniaki tuonut niin paljon tänne Suome, ettei tossa ihminen naosta.
Ei mulla muuta, hei.